merci merci beaucoup pour pour votre
temps je suis très heureux qu'on puisse
reproduire ce même type d'échange que
celui qu'on avait eu lors de ma mission
précédente dans le cadre de sa mission
parlementaire auprès du gouvernement
Charles Rodwell député de la première
circonscription desivlin organisé une
table ronde ce mercredi matin l'objectif
recueillir les besoins des entreprises
implantées dans les ivlines sur
l'attractivité des investissement
étranger
50 an yeline c'est le deuxème pôle
économique de l'île-defance après
défense 17000 entreprises près de 150000
emplois donc quand les entreprises et
leurs salariés de C desel sens large
vont bien l'ensemble du département va
bien raison pour laquelle depuis le
début de mes travaux parlementaires j'ai
voulu faire des evveline et de ma
circonscription plus spécifiquement le
laboratoire d'idées le laboratoire de
travail sur l'ensemble des mesures qu'on
peut porter au niveau national des
échanges des débats et parfois des
questionnements cette réunion a permis
d'aborder plusieurs points don la
fiscalité l'attractivité des talents
mais aussi la simplification des
démarches administratives on a parlé
beaucoup de l'entreprise et d'essayer de
comment augmenter notre
attractivité d'entrepreneur et comment
faire que les entreprises en France
puisse continuer à grandir je suis
content que cette réunion a eu lieu dans
un des territoires de France le plus
attractif pour nos industries qu'elle
soit française européenne ou
internationale sur un territoire on a
tous les atouts pour euh refaire de
notre pays un territoire attractif pour
nos industries 36e département visité
depuis le début de sa mission Charles
Rodwell a déjà fait la rencontre de
plusieurs élus locaux entreprises et
services de l'État dans différents
départements de France il devra rendre
un rapport assortie de propositions
législatives et réglementaires en
décembre